bonjour je me présente je suis clara
élèves en classe médias au collège la
boule
aujourd'hui nous vous présentons un
reportage sur les loisirs ont tant de
connaître notre journaliste cloud et
lisa et farid
on l enquête auprès de la classe foot et
les autres principales bonjour alors
nous avons quelques questions à vous
poser la première pourquoi avez vous
décidé de garder la création est ouverte
alors la classe foot ça fait partie du
projet d'établissement c'est un repère
pour l'établissement c'est quelque chose
d'important
les jeunes sont des jeunes et aussi des
clubs c'est important pour eux pouvoir
garder un minimum d'entraînement et de
pouvoir avoir une activité physique avec
la koica protocole sanitaire avez vous
mis en place par le protocole sanitaire
pour la classe foule c'est surtout
d'éviter les contacts rapprochés vos
chats c'est plutôt le professeur qui
entraîne une classe foot qui a mis en
place le protocole avec des exercices où
il ya la distance de sécurité
nous ne disons pas le mas qui sont assez
éloignées c'est souvent beaucoup je
passe des choses et la dernière être
optimiste pour aller retour des matchs
m'ont pas trop
est ce que le match
parrot prend que moi connaissez avant
les publics avec des contacts rapprochés
voit sans doute avant d'autres règles
point de match les locaux
merci beaucoup bon vous la pandémie a
bouleversé les habitudes quel est
l'appel de la conduite sur vos
entraînements l'impact de la commune sur
nos entraînements et bas les matches
passent et sans contact ont fait moins
de matches on essaye de garder le mètre
de distance
j'espère que ça va bientôt revenir les
contacts parce que c'est un élément
essentiel dans le football
du coup nos entraînements sont perturbés
malgré la cohue 8 août mois durant
lequel toujours rang d'ennemi
moi j'ai toujours la motivation car
j'aime trop le foot oui mon motivation
reste la même j'aime bien avec qui fait
la section du coup je vais continuer à
faire du football à la section faute
des fois je suis en classe j'attends un
climat de la section j'adore le football
j'aime bien mes camarades la section ça
sert à nous améliorer pour que en club
ou non soit plus fort et ça pour qu'on
prend du plaisir à jouer au foot mersen
trois journalistes aux personnes
interviewées
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée et ma
cotisation